so max do you them you've written like I
said you've written a book on this yet
you might you told me offline that you
part you have an argument that would
argue that that maybe we're not simple
maybe we're not a simulation after all
so where does that land yeah
so before giving a counter-argument give
them the pro argument so of course so
you can give arguments in both
directions here it's fun to argue with
yourself David mentioned I've seen the
argument the idea of a state simulated
in the matrix and in science fiction
going even longer far beyond that but
the guy who really started forcing
scientists to take this a bit more
seriously and gave us a D a bit more
scientific street cred I think is a nick
bostrom my fellow Swede Nick's Buu strim
who published this very dry academic
article this pointing out that is a
philosopher indeed indeed and he pointed
out that it seems like the laws of
physics allow us to build amazingly
powerful computers way beyond what we
have now solar system sized things which
could simulate mines it would feel just
like us and then he went on to say you
know it seems overwhelming me like leave
if you don't wipe out here on earth that
in the future the vast majority of all
computations and all Minds will be
inside of such computer and therefore he
said if almost all mines are simulated
we're probably simulated so that's the
pro argument now sounds good but so just
to clarify so what you're saying is if
if simulating universes becomes a
pastime among those who have access to
high powerful to highly powerful
computers and we are in a universe we
are probably in a simulated universe
even if one of those universes is
actually real right that's based on
Sarah that's the fair summary yeah and
if you're not sure at the end of the
night whether you're actually simulated
or not my advice to you is go out there
and the really interesting lives and do
unexpected things so the simulators
don't get bored and shut these out
is that the cause of death okay into the
counter-argument if you just take neck
seriously it's the cause of death
something fishy here because suppose you
buy into this and you're like okay I'm
sold on on the next argument we are
simulated let's talk then about our
simulated universe we're measuring the
laws of physics here and the simulated
world they're the same and we find that
in simulated world we can build all
these supercomputers in the future and
there will be all these simulated minds
and so on and we can make the same
argument all over again and convince
ourselves that actually we're doubly
simulated and then we're simulation in
the simulation and then you can repeat
the argument again and say well okay
we're a simulation and simulation but in
the future they're gonna be all these
simulated simulated computers and
they're gonna hell is mine so I actually
Triple E simulated no work drew please
simulated and it goes on and all all
night
and the turtles all right this point
that yet the st. you feeling that
there's something rotten at the core of
this argument okay the answer is we're
at level 42 137 that's the
fine-structure constant force and I
think I think where the where the
problem lies is that the when you make
this argument right about what kind of
minds are really the most common the
more the simulator is non simulate it
assumes the answer that you have to know
what the actual laws of physics are but
if we start making these serve arguments
we have no clue what the laws of physics
are it doesn't matter what the law is
here in our simulation if it is one R we
need to know what the real laws of
physics are and the basement huge
universe is the foundation and so we
don't really have access to that so that
that's this philosophical nitpick which
seems to me swept under the rug here